welcome to the program myanmar has seen
its worst day of violence since its
military seized power nearly two months
ago
local media are reporting as many as 50
people have been shot dead
in the latest crackdown against
anti-coup protesters
now that's on top of the 320 deaths that
rights groups have confirmed since the
start of the military coup
although the true number is likely to be
much higher the violence coincides with
a military parade
in the capital where the leader of the
ruling junta pledged to
safeguard democracy let's get the very
latest from tony cheng
who's in bangkok in neighboring thailand
just monitoring events for us from there
tony uh during the last few hours we've
been getting an
ongoing increasing death toll as that
crackdown
continues by the military
indeed and it's rising quickly we've
been
it's very hard to get a really accurate
impression we were trying to do that
earlier in the day
trying to double check and confirm these
reports we were getting of fatalities
but as the day has gone on the numbers
have just been increasing
faster and faster it is of course very
difficult to access information
in addition to which uh the internet is
still blocked in many areas but
we do know the protesters went out very
early this morning in yangon they've
been out since 4
30 in the morning it's 2 30 in the
morning
then the security services moved in at
four o'clock we understand that four
people were killed
in clashes there in dana and yangon
in last year in shan state uh several
people were killed again when the
protesters went out onto the streets
they were met as they have been day
after day
by volleys of tear gas rubber bullets
and live rounds
and in yangon in mandalay um
myanmar's second city uh the city is
basically wreathed in smoke as the
security services went in
first setting a light um barricades the
protesters have put in place around
their neighborhoods
to try and stop the security services
getting on getting in
and since then we've seen lots of people
both injured
and dead it follows a chilling warning
that went out
last night on myanmar's state tv
that people should not throw their lives
away
uh the the warning said that but if they
did come out in the streets today they
would be
shot in the head or the back and that's
what we're seeing a lot of these
injuries uh and fatalities appear to be
gunshot wounds
uh to the head we've also seen on social
media lots of images
of snipers in high-end placements all
over the country
and of course this news all comes on the
day that the armed forces parade
actually happened as well a show of
might and subliminal messages about
who we are as a military and what we can
do
uh absolutely frankly not that
subliminal we were expecting this to be
a big day from the military i think the
protesters were also expecting it
uh they came out very early in the
morning before the sun had risen
in nepador the capital and on this huge
parade ground we saw armed vehicles
missile launchers
tanks and then as the sun rose thousands
and thousands of soldiers representing
all of the armed forces but of course
while this is a day that celebrates
myanmar's military uh the glories of the
past
the biggest battle today concerning the
military is the battle against its own
people
on the streets of towns and cities all
across the country
we saw the hunters leader general minong
lai come out
he said that the military was put in
this position trying to paint the
military
as the guardian of democracy saying that
they'd been put in this position and
they'd carried out the coup
illegally because of unlawful acts by
the nld
at the party led by aung san tsuchi but
of course
he presented no arguments as he hasn't
done since the coup
and again i think we can see from the
reaction of the protesters out on the
streets who are risking their lives to
oppose this coup
that no one really believes that tony
chang in bangkok for us thanks very much